ITV management have come in for some
criticism for the way they've handled
the whole situation around his departure
well a spokesperson for ITV has put out
a statement which reads further to our
statement last night ITV can confirm
that when rumors of a relationship
between Phillip Schofield and an
employee of ITV first began to circulate
in early 2020 ITV investigated both
parties were questioned and both
categorically and repeatedly denied the
rumors as did Phillips then agency in
addition ITV spoke to a number of people
who worked on this morning and were not
provided with and did not find any
evidence of a relationship Beyond
hearsay and rumor Philip's statement
yesterday reveals that he lied to people
at ITV from Senior Management to fellow
presenters to his agency to the media
and to others over this relationship
that statement just in from ITV